[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE ELLIOTT: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We host these webinars
every Tuesday.
So welcome.
Today, we are going to
talk through robot games,
how to use TensorFlow
to build a system that
can see, understand,
and react to the world.
As a reminder, you
can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we've got Googlers standing
by to answer the questions.
So let's talk about
robot games, how
to build this system
to see, understand,
and react to the real world.
So to start off,
I'm Dave Elliott,
and I work in Google's Cloud.
And I spend most my time
working on machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
NOAH NEGREY: As do I.
And I also work in Cloud.
I'm a developer programs
engineer working
with the Cloud AI teams.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So, great.
Let's go ahead and
jump straight in.
So this is what we
built. This is a project
that we worked on for a few
months earlier this year.
And this is what it looked like
in its final manifestation.
So what you're looking
at here is four arenas
of what we called AI in Motion,
which is these robot games.
And let's take a closer look
at what this looked like.
It was the individual
standing around this arena.
This is one of the arenas.
You can see the robots--
the balls themselves--
you can see the
obstacles, and people
interacting and having lots
of fun interacting with them.
And so what we wanted
to be able to do
was to take this
project that Noah
and I and a few other
folks worked on,
and make it
available for anybody
to go and build
yourselves, and go
and have some fun with your
kids or your significant other.
So let's go ahead
and take a look
at what this looks
like in action itself.
So this is what
the AI system sees.
And this is how it's
seeing, understanding,
and reacting to the world.
This probably won't make
a lot of sense right now.
But hopefully by the
end of this webinar,
you'll be able to understand
what's happening here,
and again, to be able to
go and do this yourself.
Maybe you can get
some of these robots,
and go have some fun
at the holiday season.
OK so let's talk about
what we're going to--
actually, right up front, what
I wanted to be able to share
is that all of these resources
are in fact available for you
today.
So you can go to GitHub and
look up Cloud Platform Next,
AI in Motion.
And all the source code
is available for you.
I also wanted to quickly
call out the hardware.
It's this relatively
inexpensive,
easy-to-find hardware.
So we used the Sphero Robotic
Balls, the SPRK+ in fact.
And then we used Pixel
and Huawei phones.
We actually showed this demo
in London, San Francisco,
and Tokyo.
And so you can use both the
Pixel and the Huawei P20.
OK, so here's what we're
going to walk through today.
First, the design and
architecture decisions we made.
And then Noah's going to walk
through the model selection
and training, and the
on-device deployment.
And then we'll
finish with Q & A.
And again, you can
ask questions anytime.
We've got Googlers
standing by to answer.
And Noah and I will
answer what we can.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, at the end.
DAVE ELLIOTT: All
right, so let's
go ahead and jump into
the design architecture.
So the design goals-- we
had four basic design goals
when we started this project.
The first was we wanted
to be able to leverage
the cloud and the real world.
So we want to be able
to take the cloud
and use the cloud for
complex training--
intensive and complex--
but we also want
to be able to deploy
this in the real world,
actually onto robots
themselves, not just on a game
on the internet or something.
The next is we want to
leverage existing tools.
So great things are built
on the shoulders of giants.
We wanted to be able
to leverage those tools
and so we can move quickly
and get results quickly.
We also wanted to use as
much automation as possible
so that we can sort of
lower the cost of training,
which is one of the most
significant costs of machine
learning.
And then finally, we
wanted to have fun.
We wanted this to be as much
fun as it was educational.
And that's why we created
these robotic games.
The key architecture decisions
we made through the process--
first, I mentioned
earlier, cloud training.
So we wanted to be able to use
the cloud for rapid iteration
in order to improve
our models quickly,
to be able to lower the cost of
using the latest cutting-edge
hardware--
TPUs and GPUs, for instance,
and to really only pay
for what we use.
The second architectural
decision we made was we
wanted to make sure that
we had focus on the models
or optimization of the models.
So what that meant
ultimately was
we ended up with two
separate models-- one model
to be able to see and
understand the world, which
Noah will walk through in a
minute, for object detection.
And the second is
we wanted to have
a model that gave the right path
for direction for the gameplay.
And that ended up-- we
called it a commander model.
NOAH NEGREY: So Dave, we
mentioned at the beginning
that we both are
on the Cloud team.
So why are we focusing
on-device prediction?
DAVE ELLIOTT: So
it's a good question.
But to me, I think it's because
of the emerging use cases that
are really interesting, the
disconnected world of devices,
like a warehouse and you're
doing inventory management.
Or a manufacturing
facility, a plant,
you want to look at defects
in what's being built,
or security.
So you've got these
the disconnected,
not-always-on
devices, and you want
to be able to do the
prediction in realtime
with these disconnected devices.
So low latency, disconnected,
and predictions,
to mimic the real world.
The hardware decisions were
pretty straightforward.
We ended up looking at a bunch
of really inexpensive and fun
robots.
We selected the Sphero robots.
They're really
easy to work with,
a very simple set of APIs.
And we also used the
Pixel 2 and the 2XL.
And I mentioned the
Huawei P20 phone.
Really, it could have
been any Android devices.
These are just ones
that were easily
available and easy to work with.
The machine learning process--
this is where I think Noah will
walk through the second half
of this webinar.
If you're not familiar
with machine learning,
I highly recommend taking a look
at "AI Adventures" from Yufeng
Guo, "The 7 Steps of
Machine Learning."
I've summarized it here--
the process we went through--
to four steps.
We first gathered and
prepared the data.
Remember, machine learning is
really about using examples--
or in this case,
examples are the data--
in order to make predictions.
So we simulated some data.
And Noah will walk
through that again.
Choosing a model-- and
as I mentioned before,
we ended up with two models,
one for object detection,
and one for--
the commander for making
decisions on directions.
The third step is
really the heart
of it-- the training,
the evaluation,
and the tuning of the model.
And then finally, this
on-device prediction,
actually being able to use these
inexpensive, easily available,
disconnected devices
to make predictions.
So this is robot games.
And we looked at a
lot of different games
that we could have played, and
we settled on these four games.
And they really are sort of
a snapshot of chaser games.
We created these four
games in particular.
The first was Bot Freeze Tag.
And this is where,
working together,
humans compete in a
game of freeze tag
against an individual AI robot.
An individual robotic-controlled
robot would touch each player,
freeze them, and
individual humans
would have to run around
and unfreeze each other.
Then we switched it around, and
we created Human Freeze Tag,
where there was an
individual human trying
to freeze the
AI-controlled robots,
and AI-controlled robots
would unfreeze each other.
The third one is what we
called Zombie Apocalypse.
And this was a little
bit like the freeze tag,
except in this case,
it was-- actually,
this is one of the
most popular ones--
when you're tagged,
the human becomes
a part of the model
that chases or pursues
the other human players.
And then finally we
played a traditional game
of Capture the Flag.
And you scored based
upon how quickly you're
able to capture the other flag.
And I'm running over just
designated points in the game.
OK, so those were the
architecture decisions
we made, the game design.
And at this stage, I'm
going to had it over
to Noah, who's going to
walk through model selection
and training.
NOAH NEGREY: All right, sweet.
Let's jump in.
So as Dave was
saying, the first step
is data gathering and
preparation process.
And so the key
thing for us is, we
didn't have a large data set
already of Sphero robots,
with images and labels.
So we needed to
generate that data set.
And going through, we
could do it by hand,
taking pictures, going back,
manually labeling them.
But that would take forever.
So we wanted to
generate our data set.
And so what we have here
is, on that top image,
this blank canvas image
of our arena floor,
and then a cropped
image on the right.
And so we start placing these
randomly around the image.
What you see on the bottom is
these randomly placed objects.
And when we randomly place
them with a simple Python
script using the
Pillow library, we also
get the coordinates
of where they are
and the type that we placed.
So this is sort of our
feature and label data set.
And so then, now that we've
generated this data set,
we can generate
like 1,200 images
and convert it to a
TensorFlow record.
And so the idea behind
that is that TensorFlow
uses these TF records to
quickly access data-- as well
as the labels during training--
to help speed up the process.
So we'll talk about the
conversion script a little bit
later, and how we used it.
But after that, we upload our
data up to Google Cloud Storage
so that we can store it.
Because this is 1,200 images--
large, several gigabytes.
And so we need to be able
to access it quickly.
And if we want to run
multiple models at once,
we want to make sure
they can all access
that data at the same time.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So two
things I'll say that that.
One is-- this goes back to
what I've mentioned before--
we want to leverage automation.
And so these are virtual.
The 1,200 items
that Noah mentioned,
these are virtual items.
It could have been 12,000.
It could have been 120,000.
So we were trying to leverage
automation as much as possible.
And the second thing is,
it might make sense for us
to explain what TensorFlow
is since TensorFlow
is at the heart of
what we used here.
NOAH NEGREY: So TensorFlow is
a machine learning framework.
So there's a bunch of different
frameworks out there--
Scikit-learn, PyTorch--
but TensorFlow
is what we used, also because
of TensorFlow Lite, which we'll
dig into later,
that has a great use
for embedded and mobile devices.
So that's a sort of a library
in Python and other languages--
Node.js [INAUDIBLE] JavaScript.
But let's jump in now.
So we're going to be
talking about the two
different models we had.
So we have the object
detection model.
This is our understanding model.
At the beginning, we said we
can see, understand, and react.
So our object detection model is
where we do our understanding.
And we're also going be
talking about our commander
model in tandem here, about how
we react to the environment.
So when we first started,
we kind of looked around,
leveraging out the
resources we had,
to see what things out
there that we could use.
And right from the
beginning, TensorFlow
has, on their GitHub,
simple Android applications
that go and provide, basically,
a simple app that already does
object detection
with a model in there
to do keyboard recognition,
general person recognition,
maybe like water bottle
recognition, very
simple things, and shows you how
to run TensorFlow on an Android
app.
So we grabbed that off
of their GitHub repo,
and just started with that.
But the problem with that was
we didn't get our custom sort
of prediction of
our Sphero robots
from that data set
that we generated.
So then we had to decide, hey,
we need a custom sort of object
detection model, and that--
DAVE ELLIOTT: You're saying
that you have millions
of pictures of Sphero robots--
NOAH NEGREY: No, they didn't--
DAVE ELLIOTT:
--already in the model.
NOAH NEGREY: Oddly enough, no.
So we had to build
our own model.
And so but the nice thing
was, we could take--
TensorFlow has this thing, what
they call the Object Detection
API.
And that's going to be that
bottom resource, the MobileNets
Open-Source Models for
Efficient Vision On-Device.
And so what that is
is basically there's
these pre-trained models,
frozen at checkpoints, that do
object detection very well.
But what they don't have is
very specific object detection.
And so we can take our
data set with that model,
run it through training
by modifying just some
of the configuration files,
and get a brand new model
out that is now trained to do
object detection on our models.
And the code for that
can sound intimidating.
You're like whoa,
I don't know how
to do this object detection.
But let's look at
the next slide,
and just see sort of
what we have to modify.
And so what we take here is we
see, modifying just a few lines
in the configuration file of
the input path and the label map
path.
And what's happening
there is we just
are modifying that
TF record that we
uploaded to Google Cloud
Storage, and adding those in.
And then we run the scripts that
we got as part of this model
to run the training job.
So next, let's talk about
some of those decisions
we made for the commander model.
That's the reacting model.
And so the idea
behind this model
is we've got the bounding boxes
that you see in that image
there.
We've figured out where
things are on the image.
We've understood
our environment.
But now let's make a decision.
And that's where this
model's coming in,
more built from scratch,
to make a decision
on what the model should do.
And so this model is using
reinforcement learning.
And this is a technique
where you're basically
playing a bunch of
games over and over,
and then giving it a scoring
system to see how well it did,
and just learning from
that scoring system.
Because we don't
really know what
the optimal path is
in every situation
when the balls are actually
out there moving around.
And so that's how we
used the commander model.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So we've
got the object detection
to see the world, to understand
the world, these objects
and the obstacles
that are out there.
And then commander
model is the one
that actually plays
the game, the one that
knows the rules of
the game and makes
the determination as to
what the right path is
in order for the [INAUDIBLE]
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah,
well, not quite.
It doesn't really need to
know the rules of the game.
It just needs to know--
we can teach it the
rules of the game
later, with reinforcement
learning, to play using just--
DAVE ELLIOTT: It doesn't
know the rules of the game,
but it knows what's
a successful path.
NOAH NEGREY: Yes.
We give it back that
scoring while training.
We're telling it what
the correct path is.
So now the next part is
actually training this model,
and running it, and learning
from it, and evaluating.
And so the key
thing to that is we
can take advantage
of cloud resources,
using Google Cloud Machine
Learning Engine for training
of both models.
And so the idea
behind this is, when
we're training these
models, we need
a lot of compute resources.
And we also have
to access the data.
And so this is the nice
thing that Google offers,
is we have all these
resources and compute.
We can run many simulations
at once, many training jobs,
and be able to access that data
out of the TensorFlow record.
And so the key thing
to this is there
are simple one-time setups
for this cloud training stuff.
And you can follow the
links to those GitHubs.
DAVE ELLIOTT: About how
long did it take to do this?
NOAH NEGREY: The
simple one-time setup?
Oh, 15, maybe 20 minutes.
And we'll talk in the next
slide about a resource we
used that basically
tells you how
to do this whole process with
a slightly more specific model,
in about 30 minutes,
for object detection.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, great.
NOAH NEGREY: So
let's look at that.
We've got our sample
application we have
that we just need
to get a model for.
We're going to train our
custom object detection model.
And now we just need to sort
of start that training job.
And so there's actually
three amazing resources
out there, these
three blog posts--
Sara Robinson is the author
of the first and third one,
Dat Tran is the
author of the second--
that basically walk
through these exact steps
with very simple
specific resources
on doing object detection.
As you can see on
the bottom one,
it's getting started
in 30 minutes.
So you're up and running
with a mobile application,
doing object detection
on your phone
in 30 minutes with a
cloud training job,
using your cloud TPUs--
kind of amazing.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And this
is another example
of using resources that
exist in the TensorFlow
community and the
broader community
to be able to shorten the
time to get to actually
the gameplay itself.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, definitely.
So then what we talked about is
our second model, the commander
model, being run in simulation.
So what you see right there
is our actual simulation
happening.
So our model is
using simulations
so that we can run it faster,
run multiple training jobs.
It's less expensive.
We don't need to actually
run multiple games
in the physical environment,
keep logging the data,
and then go back
and sort of upload
that, and train from that.
No, we can use this
simulation data
to get near realtime sort of
what happens in the real world.
And the idea behind this is that
the red ball is the one doing
reinforcement learning.
So its sort of
objective is to try
to move toward that target
point, the yellow ball, which
is stationary.
And it's trying to move
around and get to that.
And then the blue
ball is our chaser,
sort of just doing a simple
scripted thing to directly
after the red ball.
And the red ball is
trying to learn from that.
And the idea of this
is it's a "target
point" and "point to avoid"
structure of initial model
simulations, that we
can create our chaser
and runner from the same model.
And the idea from
our experimentation
led to this "peak
and valley" model,
what is more efficient and sort
of realistic for our runner
than other things we did.
And so the idea behind
this is, imagine
that the blue ball is this
peak of a mountain which moves.
And this yellow is this pit that
we can either keep stationary
or move around.
And red is sort of being
pulled towards the yellow pit.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Kind
of like gravity.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, gravity,
sort of falling away
from the blue ball.
And this is sort of a common-ish
technique in robot pathfinding.
And to make this a little
bit more realistic,
we also added a
aggressiveness rating.
And the idea behind this
was we would sort of weight
how much we wanted to
fall away from blue,
or sort of more
push into yellow.
And so this allowed us
to create two behaviors.
When used as the chaser, you
can move the target point around
to the nearest Sphero robot that
you're trying to chase after,
and the nearest obstacle being
one of those white blocks
you want to avoid.
And when the runner,
you can kind of
keep this stationary
general area
you want to move towards, with
the primary objective being
to run away from the nearest
blue ball or the nearest
chasing robot.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And
so this is really
the heart of the commander
model, which is really
the heart of the engine that
learned to play these games,
right?
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And
on top of that,
this also points out again
the example of-- or the use
of automation, that we
want to be able to--
if we'd have done this
in the real world,
you need lots and
lots of examples
to be able to train your models.
This would have taken
weeks or months,
and cost hundreds
of thousands, maybe,
to have the many, many
iterations of this.
What you've done
here is essentially
simulate those games.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
And one thing you might
be thinking is like, OK,
for chasing, why not just use
a search algorithm like A*
or Optimized.
And that's true.
You can totally do that.
We started with that
in our prototype,
and it works really well.
But then when we wanted to make
that running away decision,
you have to know
where you want to go.
And that's that optimal
decision we don't exactly
know the answer to, where we
decided to create this model
and use it in both cases
of chasing and running,
which created some very
interesting behaviors we saw
out on the actual arena floor.
So let's kind of
do a little recap
of all the different tools we
used in this training, and sort
of decision-making process.
So first up, going back to
that beginning, Cloud Storage,
using Google Cloud Storage
to hold our TensorFlow
record of 1,200 images
or so in our data set,
and slowly increasing throughout
time as we generate more data.
And then TensorFlow,
that machine
learning framework,
again, that we're
using because the TensorFlow
object Detection API has
all this vast resources that
we have out there to use,
as well as the TensorFlow Lite,
which we'll be talking about
shortly.
Cloud Machine Learning Engine--
we use that to run
many simulation jobs,
speed up our training
using GPUs and TPUs.
And the cool thing
with that is, by
doing that, we can speed up our
training to sort of cut down
our training time, from
running in about eight hours
with Cloud TPU, down to about
an hour and a half to two hours,
that we can iterate multiple
times in a day instead
of just once a day.
DAVE ELLIOTT: That's
from GPU to TPU.
NOAH NEGREY: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And TPUs are the
TensorFlow Processing Units.
These are custom-built
ASICs that are specifically
designed to run
in Google's Cloud
to do the types of
math that's required--
the matrix type of math that's
required to do the training.
Training is the most intensive
part of the machine learning
process, at least from
a compute perspective.
And so having this
custom-built ASICs that really
increase the speed and
lower the cost of training
is a really important
part of being
able to do this in a
quick and inexpensive way.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
And then we were able to use the
Google Compute engines to run
our simulations on
that commander model,
by running multiple
simulations at once
so we aren't just focusing
all our resources locally.
So next up, let's talk about
the on-device deployment.
So we have our models
trained, selected,
and we're ready to use them.
We just need to put
them into action.
And so that's where we finally
get to TensorFlow Lite.
And so TensorFlow
Lite is a solution
for running machine
learning models
on mobile and embedded devices.
And the reason for
that is TensorFlow Lite
has this cool
quantization feature.
And the idea behind that is
that, for these deep learning
models, these models
that are very large,
you can shrink the model size
by removing certain layers.
And you're trading
off accuracy to get
smaller models that run faster.
And this is really
important in mobile.
And the reason for that
is mobile applications
are typically maybe
30 megabytes in size.
And if you add on a 30 megabyte
model size, that's a bad thing.
It doubles your size.
And I believe there's
requirements size
on these applications.
So by cutting them down
to about 2 megabytes,
you lose maybe a percent or two
of accuracy, but what you get
is a significantly faster
model, cutting, potentially,
your inference time--
your prediction time,
what it takes to do the
object detection-- in half
to a smaller model.
And so this enables
the machine learning
inference with low
latency and a small binary
size, which can run
on Android, iOS,
and other operating systems.
And by converting
to TensorFlow Lite,
there's already existing
scripts to take your TensorFlow
model as is and convert
it to TensorFlow Lite.
And so that's again
where we point out
to that blog post of
training and serving
a realtime mobile
object detector in 30
minutes with Cloud TPUs.
It will help you run that
conversion script for you.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And this
is another one of the--
as you mentioned
before, one of the key
reasons that we
chose TensorFlow.
Not only is TensorFlow
wildly popular,
so there's lots of resources--
I think it was open-sourced
in October of 2015,
and at this stage, it's by far
the most popular open source
library out there--
but also the fact
that TensorFlow Lite was
designed for use cases
just like this.
NOAH NEGREY: Yes.
Yeah, for mobile or
in embedded devices.
So now we kind of have
this diagram flowing.
We have our training in the
cloud, those resources that we
went over, and then
we're converting it
to TensorFlow Lite.
Now we just need to put it
on the Android application.
And so this we're going to be
serving on-device and talking
to our Sphero robots.
So we're talking to
the Sphero robots
over their Bluetooth
with their SDK.
And so the idea of
this model deployment
is there's sort of
a loop happening.
What happens is the
object detection model
informs the commander model.
So when it goes and does
the object detection,
it's understanding
where things are
and then sending
that information out
to the commander model.
The commander model is then
taking that information
and making a prediction.
It's saying, which angle
should I go, what direction.
And the key thing is,
the Sphero robot's SDK
allows you to input an
angle of 360 degrees.
And our commander model
is making a decision
in 20-angle-degree increments.
So it's saying, cool, go
this way, go that way.
And so that information then
gets sent to our robots.
And so then this
loop again repeats.
We do the object
detection, we observe--
DAVE ELLIOTT: And the 20
angles was just arbitrary--
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah,
relatively arbitrary.
We just wanted to slim it
down because we didn't quite
need full 360-degree support.
20-degree angles was enough
of a small percentage
to get good behavior out.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Somebody else can
do it in different increments
if they need more precision.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Right, OK.
NOAH NEGREY: Again, part
of the iterating and sort
of process of trying
something, seeing
how it works once
it's out on the world,
and then bringing it back in.
And so in general,
this whole loop
of running object detection
and commander model
takes about 60 to
80 milliseconds.
That's the inference time
slash decision-making time.
And that is near-ish realtime to
happening on the arena, where,
as the balls are moving, we
understand where they are,
as we saw in that
initial video--
where they're moving around,
and then making a decision based
on that information.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So that's the
scene, the understanding
and the reacting, 60
to 80 milliseconds.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, all of them.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Which
again, seems like it
would be fantastic in
the physical world.
If it's an online game
or something like that,
that might be problematic.
But here, it's actually
seeing the direction
and the obstacles, and
making determinations
in 60-80 milliseconds.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
So now we can see that whole
diagram coming together.
But then the last
piece that's missing
is that multiplayer aspect
that we said, where people--
DAVE ELLIOTT: The humans.
NOAH NEGREY: --yeah, the humans
are coming in and interacting,
and playing with
these AI robots.
So that's where we added this
second part using Firebase.
And Firebase is Google's sort
of mobile platform for cloud.
And the idea behind
this is we can
have our devices communicating.
And we use the Firebase
Realtime Database.
And the idea behind this is
that that realtime database
is holding our game state
and information of who
is "it," who is
allowed to move, if you
got tagged and are frozen, or
if you turned into a zombie.
And so we're using that realtime
database with low latency
to be able to update that game
state as things are happening,
so that the central
phone running the object
detection in commander model
is actually also running
sort of the general game state,
and sending information off
to the Firebase.
And the other devices
that the humans walk up to
and we start playing with
to interact with our robots
get that update in realtime.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And in this
case, the human players
are using phones as well.
NOAH NEGREY: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: With
a simple app on it.
And they could've been using
joysticks or any other input
device.
And I guess it probably
makes sense to leave this
up just for a minute longer.
Because this is really the
snapshot of the whole system.
On the far left side, you've
got the training in the cloud
that I mentioned before as
one of the key tenets of what
we wanted to do.
You can see the storage
and the training
using TensorFlow, Google Cloud
Storage, Compute Engine, TPUs.
The conversion-- that happens
in the middle, TensorFlow
and TensorFlow Lite.
And then off to the
right side, serving
on-device with both of our
models, the object detection,
the scene, and the
commander models
are really the right model
for the right job at hand.
And then the Sphero
robots themselves,
that are both being
seen by object detection
and being controlled
through the commander model.
And then the bottom
being just the gameplay,
the human interaction
component of it.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, exactly.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
NOAH NEGREY: So let's jump
back to that initial video
and sort of walk through it
again now that we have it.
So the idea behind this is I am
the green ball, moving around.
I'm about to go and the AI bots
that are controlled elsewhere.
And we're seeing that object
detection happen in realtime.
And so I've tagged
orange, pink, and red.
And blue is still moving
around and making the decision
to go untag its frozen
teammates and start
running away again, and then, as
it loops around that top block,
to go back and untag
the other teammates.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And
the white boxes
are just obstacles that
are [INAUDIBLE] scene,
you try to avoid?
NOAH NEGREY: Trying to add a
challenging factor to the game.
DAVE ELLIOTT: All right.
So to summarize, we built
this system this year.
It wasn't a huge involvement
in terms of time or resources.
But it was a really fun project.
See, understand, and react
to the real world, leverage
existing resources to be
able to build this quickly.
The key things are
you're able to train
a complex model in the cloud.
Leverage all the
benefits of Cloud--
since we're wearing
the T-shirts here--
but then deploy them
in the real world,
deploy them, in this case, on
just sort of fun Sphero robots
to play these fun little games.
But again, it could be
a robot in a warehouse,
or a manufacturing
plant, or in security,
or a whole host of
other use cases.
The other thing I'll
point out, in summary,
is that all of these
tools are available today.
TensorFlow and TensorFlow
Lite are open source.
Cloud machine Learning
Engine, GCS in the cloud
are easy to use and
relatively inexpensive to use.
You only pay for what you use.
In this case, part of
it is the training.
And all of these examples, all
these sample codes and blog
posts are really
readily available.
You can go out and use
them today, build them,
play with them over the
holidays, and then modify them,
and build something even better.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah.
And as we pointed out,
all of the resources,
specifically the
source code on that
link we put at the beginning,
of the GitHub, Next 18
AI in Motion, has all
the source code links
to blog posts that go
even more in-depth,
as well as the other resources
that we used to build this.
So definitely go
and check it out.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, great.
So please stay tuned
for live Q & A.
You can still enter
those questions,
and we'll be back in less
than a minute to answer
your questions.
OK, welcome back.
It looks like we've
got some questions
from the live audience.
Let's go ahead and start
with the first one.
Can you explain why you
use TensorFlow Lite?
So going back to what we
mentioned before, really it's
a question of, I
think, first, why
we want to use an embedded
solution in a mobile solution.
That really goes
down to, again, I
think, a really unique and
interesting emerging use case.
We're still really
early in the game.
As compute resources continue
to become less expensive,
as these mobile devices
become more and more powerful,
we'll be able do more and
more of the inference, more
and more of the prediction
on these devices.
And I think that's
the first question,
is that there's
really interesting use
cases that TensorFlow
Lite can address.
And in terms of why we
use TensorFlow Lite,
I think it's fair to say-- well,
Noah, you made that decision.
NOAH NEGREY: Yeah, so I
think it goes back to the--
you can run TensorFlow and
TensorFlow Lite on Android.
But the key difference
with TensorFlow Lite
is you get that
quantization step
in when you're speeding up
and shrinking your model size,
without losing much accuracy.
And so by doing that, you have
your low-latency fast model
without even having
to go up to the cloud.
So you've got your
training model on-device,
so you're not costing any
data going out to the cloud,
and you're not incurring any
network latency cost usage.
So that's sort of the
main key thing there,
is that you're keeping it
locally on-device for faster
things, and you're not
costing your users data
when they're running it.
DAVE ELLIOTT: I think it's fair.
I would also add to that that,
generally speaking, anything
you do in TensorFlow now is
becoming easier and easier
because there's such a
robust ecosystem now.
There's so much
information out there
that can help you
do what we've done,
which is deliver
this pretty quickly.
Second thing--
what's the biggest
obstacles in doing this?
Where did you hit
your roadblocks?
Ooh, we hit a fair
number of roadblocks.
NOAH NEGREY: Well, I'd say
the first biggest obstacle
with machine learning in general
is sort of being overwhelmed
by either the task
and the problem
or the amount of
resources out there,
and trying to sift through.
And so I think that's the
initial burden, of like, oh,
wow, this is a huge space.
It's daunting.
At least it was for me
when we started this.
But going out, and sort
of digging through,
and finding these different
resources that we have,
you can see, oh, wow,
they do a really good job
of explaining, walking
you through the steps,
and so forth.
I think the biggest
roadblock we really
hit was actually with
our commander model.
And that was actually--
when we deploy it,
we have our simulations,
they look great,
but some of the behaviors
that we would then deploy,
we learned, oh dear,
this doesn't really
work in the real world, or
it learns a bad behavior.
So if our reward system was
poor in our initial commander
models, the Sphero
robot sort of just
learned, hey, if I go move to
the wall, and just stay there,
and don't move, that's the
best decision I can make,
because our reward system
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
giving it back.
We gave it a poor reward
system where that was its best
score it could determine.
And so by modifying that, and
moving to that target and point
thing, with the mountain
falling away and gravity,
we got a better simulation out,
which then also worked really
well in the real world.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And I think the
an interesting thing on this
is I think some of the biggest
obstacles that you might hit
are, ironically, the
physical part of it--
the mat, the walls, the camera
being suspended onto the arena.
None of it is
terribly difficult,
but it does take some
effort to be able to set up
an environment like that.
Initially, we used 2
by 4's and LEGO bricks
to suspend the camera in place.
And ultimately, what you
saw in the images earlier
were things that
were put together
by an interactive
professional agency,
hardened so they could
go around to trade shows.
But that was actually
an interesting--
the physical development
of it was one
of the interesting challenges.
NOAH NEGREY: But the videos
we're done with our prototype--
2 by 4's, we went to
Home Depot, bought
some plywood, put
it together, done.
DAVE ELLIOTT: $50 or
less worth of equipment.
All right, can you can apply
this to other common scenarios
aside from gaming?
Yes, gaming is fun.
But as I mentioned
a few times, to me,
one of the really most evident
use cases is in a warehouse,
in inventory management.
You can set up simple cameras to
be able to look at a warehouse,
be able to track things
as they move around,
to be able to see what's
happening in that warehouse.
And then to be able to
understand that, oh, we're
short on this, we've got
an overabundance of that,
and then to make
decisions based upon what
it sees to be able to
take corrective action.
And then, ultimately, through
maybe warehouse robotics,
to be able to take that
action, to go and automatically
order a resupply,
have it delivered,
and resupply those shelves.
That's a simple
real world example.
NOAH NEGREY: On top
of that, you can also
do some defect detection.
So if you have an assembly
line sort of going by,
and you're checking your
products for defects,
you can go and monitor that as
well with this same technology.
We've done something else
with a similar thing,
using the same resources that
we had for object detection
to create something to detect
if there was a error in, say,
one of the objects moving
by, and say, hey, this
is a good object,
this is a bad one.
And then you can
use a second model
to make a decision
to react to that,
and either pull that object
aside, or make an alert
and have one of
your staff come up
and grab it, move it, and
do some manual inspection
from there.
So there's a lot of
things you can do.
It's just sort of coming up
with the idea of what to use
this object detection for.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Well, I talk a
lot about machine learning.
And it's really gotten
to the stage where you
need to think of the world as--
you have systems now that
can understand the world,
whether it's understanding
somebody speak
or understanding what's
happening in a video
or in physical pictures,
it can see the world
and understand what's
happening in the world.
And once you realize that
you can take that and put it
on disconnected
mobile devices, I
think the litany of
things you can do really
becomes interesting.
And again, we're
really early in this,
and this is just an easy way of
showing how this can be done.
I did want to touch on the
last question, which is,
can you review the
GitHub repositories?
So this should be in the
bottom of what you're
looking at on your screen.
I think we included just
about all of the links,
including the Google
Cloud Platform AI Next--
NOAH NEGREY: The repository.
DAVE ELLIOTT: --link.
NOAH NEGREY: That's
the main one that
will at least start getting
you out to the other ones
that we used.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So
hopefully we've answered
most of your questions.
If we didn't, we've got people
who are directly answering them
online.
So at this stage, we're going
to go ahead and wrap up.
Stay tuned for the next
session, Building Chatbots
with Dialogflow.
And I've been looking forward
to this, because we're out
in Mountain View.
But this one is live from New
York with Whitney, Building
Chatbots with Dialogflow.
Thanks for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]